brooklyn has a featured part and so that
keeps replaying in my mind i'm sure it's
replaying in her mother's mind you ready
leah she didn't get to sing last week
and almost went home so you can't let
the opportunity slip by you have to take
everything and you have to grasp it you
sit right here
one second i won't take a lot of your
time leah has prepared a piece on the
ukulele she just wanted to just leave
you with something positive that shows
she can sing and to show you that we're
still here we're still in it and we are
not quitters and we're not giving up
uh-huh
brooke is literally having a moment and
here comes angie trying to get leah's
part back
i'm not stupid i know exactly what
angie's doing if you think this is gonna
make it better okay fine
i'll listen to you sing thank you so
much
[Music]
they call
the rising
[Music]
come on now
andrew
let's be real
to audition again
[Music]
[Applause]
i love it it's so mature at the end of
the day i'm glad i got to hear leah sing
one more time and i do appreciate that
leah is being brave and taking a risk it
wasn't the typical pop song but i wanted
to show you i have a different side and
i can be a musician too i like that side
of you but it's not going to make me
change my mind
i'm not taking the role away from brook
and giving it back to leah
[Music]
you